y'all there's some [ __ ] up people
[Music]
what's up guys i'm josh richards and i'm
here to play answer the internet if you
found a porn online of your buddy and
his girlfriend would you watch it
i mean i guess you got to see what like
the boys are working with sometimes um
would you say anything to him 100 i'm
probably tweeting out the link
there's
would you rather spend the rest of your
life in a country music video or a rap
music video i'm gonna say rap because
i'm like not the biggest country fan and
i feel like
a lot of girls like shaking ass in a rap
video right so
i mean it's not that i wouldn't like to
you know like ride around in a like old
bronco or something it's just like uh i
don't know if i could have the country
music like playing in the background
forever a full-grown great white versus
a full-grown polar bear and an
olympic-sized swimming pool that is
seven feet deep and 75 degrees
fahrenheit who wins great white
polar bears weight that's way too warm
way too warm of water for a polar bear
75 degrees way too warm for a polar bear
way too warm for a polar bear
yeah that's not a polar bear's natural
environment no it isn't he might
die that's what i think that's what i
think yeah i mean i don't know if great
whites like to swim in super warm water
either but i just feel like polar bears
got it like they love the cold it's not
like you see great whites in the arctic
right big brain [ __ ]
sharks are still quicker but it's not
it's not a
boxing match i mean it's gonna be when
this [ __ ] polar bear gets his paws on
you okay
i don't know man
great whites
if you could get access to one person's
phone and look at their [ __ ] who would
it be i was gonna say like maybe like
donald trump right i just feel like
that'd be nuts to see what's going on in
his phone
like hillary clinton's nudes or
something if you could be a master at
one of the four bases of sex but you'd
have to be below average at every other
which one would you choose i mean home
play like you got to go that right like
you got to be good
but also if you're a horrible kisser you
might not even get you don't get that ah
i see what you mean yeah i feel like
guys don't really give a [ __ ] like yeah
they're just like uh no i'm i'm still
gonna go with the last last base fourth
base home plate what two tick talkers
would you like to see in a cage match
like you know like let's have a battle
of like who's the queen of tick tock
addison ray and charlie demilia that'd
be nuts yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
hell in the cell right now who would win
i've seen a fight video of charlie
dimelio before when she was in like
private school or whatnot and she was
dragging that girl by her hair like it
was pretty nuts it was pretty nuts so i
would say i would say but i feel like
addison's like ah i'm gonna go charlie
yeah feisty feisty hoots are out who's
hotter ariel or jasmine ariel we're
talking about like what are we talking
about here
okay that's what i thought we were
i was like
yeah
what actor or celebrity would you want
to play you in a movie um
is it like is it like they gotta look
like me type thing i mean i would say
like maybe like a timothy chalamet or
like tom holland could do it you know
what i'm saying this is awkward this is
very awkward
why is this awkward you do got like a
shallow mate look i guess
often he said i want to [ __ ] timothy
oh he's a handsome man he is a good
looking dude well
who would you rather have as a wingman
dave portnoy brianna chickenfry grace
and molly brianna easy brianna is a
great wingman would you rather have your
internet history made public or a sex
tape that goes viral
sex tape that goes viral easy yeah
like run it up
run up the checks bro
yeah but it's like if i do it it's like
weird to do it on my own and release it
you know but if it gets like leech it's
like oh no
coming soon
maybe the link will be in the
description of this video
all right mary [ __ ] kill bryce hall noah
back griffin johnson uh uh
i'm gonna marry griff he's a boy
i feel like i feel like i'm closer with
bryce but i feel like noah's a more
gentle lover
so i guess maybe i'll [ __ ] noah and then
and then kill bryce sorry dog
if you had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
aliens who would it be morgan freeman i
feel like he just says they'll be like
yo your voice is so nice you guys must
be good people
would you rather a have a flock of geese
swarm to you every time you fart that'd
be kind of funny b never use a phone or
computer again so like the only thing i
think i'm afraid of in the world is
geese like that might be my only fear
ever they're the most vicious bird in
the world yeah like i walked by a flock
of them one time like they were just
chilling out like a pier and they had
their little babies around they were it
wasn't even like a plant it was hissing
i was like i was like is there a serpent
around like what is happening
so i'm gonna say but i still i'm still
gonna say have a flock of geese swarm me
every time i fart that's like almost
like a superpower like get carried off
with the geese while you're just like
ripping ass or something
it's like yeah aquaman of the sky
um who is the one person in the world
you would least want to bang your
significant other
i mean that kind of already happened to
me
y'all are setting me up aren't ya y'all
are [ __ ] setting me up
damn pulling on the heartstrings
if you were thrown into one of the four
major sport leagues what sport and
position would you be most successful in
um probably like a center in the nba
if you had to watch your biggest enemy
[ __ ] the girl of your dreams in order
for you to marry her would you do it
y'all there's some [ __ ] up people um
no no no no
internet superstar josh richards on
answer the internet unbelievable make
sure you leave a comment below who do
you want to see next also make sure you
subscribe and click the notification
bell so you never miss a video